les shadoks passent leur temps à aller
et venir se réfugier sur la lune pour
échapper à la fureur de l'insecte gégène
monter descendre de la lune
dix vingt cent fois par jour c'est ptx
tellement c'était harassant pour les
malheureux shadoks
d'autant plus qu'il y avait le grave
problème des échelles à lui les shadoks
n'avait pas d'échelle suffisamment
adéquate aux il faut vous dire que les
shadoks n'avait pas encore inventé
l'échelle dite intégral que nous
connaissons maintenant ils étaient donc
obligés d'avoir deux sorte d'échelle
d'une part des échelles pour monter et
d'autre part des échelles pour descendre
et c'était pas les mêmes quand on
essayait de monter par exemple avec une
échelle pour décembre
eh bien ça marchait pas et même si ça
avait risqué le marché ça aurait marché
beaucoup trop lentement
de même quand on essayait de descendre
avec une échelle pour monter ça marchait
pas non plus ou plus exactement ça
marchait mais trop rapidement